but what we've decided is that we've got
a way forward for this country and for
the EU now we've got a great deal on
brexit as you know for the first time in
three and a half years Parliament voted
to endorse a way out of the EU the the
the deal I was able to do with our
friends and partners but unfortunately
they also voted to delay the final
approval of that deal that they've
endorsed and what that means I'm afraid
is if this Parliament is anything to go
by that delay could go on for a very
long time so I'm afraid it looks as
though our EU friends are going to
respond to Parliament's request by
having an extension which I really don't
want at all so the way to get this done
the way to get brexit done is I think to
be reasonable with Parliament and say if
they genuinely want more time to study
this excellent deal they can have it but
they have to agree to a general election
on December the 12th and that's the way
forward because this part has been going
on for a long time without her majority
it's refusing to deliver brexit it's
impossible to deliver legislation it's
time frankly that the opposition
summoned up the nerve to submit
themselves to the judgement of of our
collective boss which is the people of
the UK if your deal is so great as you
claim which they haven't they've just
agreed to go ahead yes yes why then try
to ram this through with the threat of
election you could go on a more
conventional timetable give a standard
of scrutiny and get on with it well no
we're going to give them the beginning
it that's a very good point we're gonna
give them all the time they want between
now and the dissolution of Parliament to
do that scrutiny that's much more than I
think that some of them have been asking
for I mean that's more I think than then
Philip Hamlet was asked well this is a
big chunk of time and it's interesting
actually in the debate on Tuesday about
brexit everybody said we need more time
to study this
deal actually the Labour Party couldn't
even find enough speakers they ran out
of speakers live alone new ideas to
bring to the table we've had three and a
half years to discuss this we're being
very very reasonable we're saying if you
genuinely might want more time you can
have it here it is but the the condition
for that is that we all agree to go for
a general election on December the 12th
and the reason for having that that
deadline is because otherwise I don't
think the people of this country are
going to believe that Parliament is
really going to do it by that deadline
because they spent three and a half
years failing to do it so let's get it
done and that's come out of EU